let's get some ready to get some wait  like I said life is always ready to get  so which is a savanna  stand by to get some steady I don't  think people recognize what that  actually means to us that we we knew we  would say this all the time in combat or  train scenarios when you knew that I  mean it is about to go down bullets will  then be flying around as low as you can  be going off and you hear someone very  clearly over the radio just in a real  combo is come up a bit  stand by to get some it's true state  right you know your song but when you  get stayed in that manner I know when  you should be let go  you didn't learn enough song and do it  that's pretty awesome  you  [Music]